am 4 oktober 1957 schickte die damalige
Sowjetunion den ersten künstlichen
Satelliten in die Erdumlaufbahn Sputnik
1 ein riesiger Meilenstein im spaceways
zwischen den USA und Russland der einen
weltweiten entwicklungsboom ins Rollen
brachte Fast Forward ins Jahr 2023
Kreisen inzwischen weit über 6000
künstliche Trabanten um unseren Planeten
ich wurde eingeladen den Start einer
neuen Generation von Satelliten zu
verfolgen der von der Ariane 5 heute
Abend ins Weltall geschossen wird wenn
die Mission erfolgreich verläuft dann
ist das der erste von vielen ESA
Satelliten die unsere Wetter und Klima
Beobachtung revolutionieren sollen wenn
sie aber scheitert dann sind über 12
Jahre Entwicklungsarbeit von hunderten
von ESA Mitarbeitern umsonst also
schnallt euch an und Gott liebt
für dieses Video hier haben wir ja mal
das Studio in Köln verlassen und uns auf
eine Reise begeben denn die coolsten
Geschichten der Wissenschaft findet man
nun mal nicht immer im Internet aber
egal ob an der Bahnsteigkante in Zug
oder im Flugzeug das Schlimmste was man
mir antun kann ist mich zu ewiger
Warterei zu verdonnern deswegen ist mein
Mittel gegen Langeweile seit jeher das
gute alte Hörbuch vor einiger Zeit habe
ich mir deswegen die App heruntergeladen
da habe ich ganz ganz viel Auswahl und
für längere Strecken ohne Internet kann
man sich da auch Hörbücher downloaden
Hörbücher höre ich zu Unterhaltung aber
auch um mich auf dem aktuellen
Wissensstand zu halten und um mich auch
über
Aktuelles informieren und zu Einstimmung
auf den Raketenstart habe ich die
verrückte Welt der Physik von Astronaut
Ulrich weitergehört weil sich nur sehr
empfehlen kann wenn ihr bucht wird auch
mal ausprobieren wollt dann benutzt
einfach den ersten Link unten in der
Videobeschreibung und benutzt unseren
Code dr Watson denn dann bekommt ihr
zwei Monate gratis und das cool ist wir
haben eine Kooperation mit das heißt ihr
unterstützt damit auch noch direkt uns
und unsere Videos und wir können
häufiger mal so cool und auch wenn ihr
die Videos wie dieses Jahr machen ich
wünsche euch ganz viel Spaß bei eurer
Testphase und wenn ihr noch eine
Empfehlung braucht das ist mehr
Unterhaltung ready Player one von Ernest
klein sehr sehr gutes Buch nicht so
guter Film aber deutlich besseres Buch
also wenn ihr den Film gesehen habt und
vielleicht ein bisschen enttäuscht wart
oder den Film gut fandet das Buch werdet
ihr auf jeden Fall noch besser finden
jetzt erstmal ganz viel Spaß mit eurer
Testphase von bookbeat und wir machen
jetzt weiter mit dem Raketenstart und
gehen zur Isar ich befinde mich gerade
in notwich in die Niederlanden wo auch
das offizielle Launch Event stattfindet
und unter anderem hier wurde auch der
super wichtige Satellit entwickelt den
die Rakete heute Abend ins Weltall
schießen soll
ich bin offiziell eingeladen wir werden
jetzt gleich durch die Space Expo
geführt und werden noch ein paar andere
coole Sachen sehen können
[Musik]
das ist die große Rakete die Ariane 5
die heute Abend starten wird in unserem
Satelliten heute in die Umlaufbahn
bringen wird freue ich mich schon sehr
darauf startet in Französisch Diana
heute Abend um 9:30 Uhr geht's los
[Musik]
[Applaus]
woher weißt du dass du bei der Esel bist
selbst der Mülleimer ist für eine Rakete
gefunden
[Musik]
bin bei der ESA okay Zeit für den Star
des Abends der mtgi1 ist ein Projekt der
ESA und eumesat und einer der
komplexesten und fortschrittlichsten
Wettersatelliten die je gebaut wurden
MTG das steht für Meteo Set third
generation der Name der Mission die uns
mit Hilfe fortschrittlicher
Sensortechnologie komplett neue und
genauere Daten zu Wetter und Klima
liefern soll der MTG i1 ist der erste
von insgesamt sechs Satelliten die sich
die nächsten 20 Jahre im geostationären
Orbit über Afrika befinden werden und im
besten Fall und unsere Wettervorhersage
revolutionieren es kommt ein großer
Sturm vom Atlantik und der schlägt
irgendwo in Frankreich ein dann wartet
mal aber die nächste Stunde ab und es
ist noch kein neuer modelllauf da und
man will wissen wo fliegt er denn jetzt
genau leise da hilft das System extrem
der kann sehr genau sagen wo die
stärksten Winde auftreten und wo der
Sturm dann wirklich auf die Küste trifft
solche Dinge ja das ist Joachim
salmüller Leiter der kleine Service
Division bei olex hat der uns erklärt
hat was den Satelliten so besonders
macht beim ersten Satelliten sind zwei
hauptsensoren an Bord das eine ist ein
Imager der wie bisher die meteosatz auch
die ganze Erdscheibe alle 10 Minuten
abscannt im infraroten Bereich damit man
auch auf nachts was sieht und auch
tagsüber im sichtbaren Teil des
Spektrums dann haben wir noch einen
Lightning imagine an Bord das ist ein
Blitz abbildendes Instrument das hat die
Spezialität das ist im Prinzip einmal
die Erdscheibe pro Millisekunde abdeckt
das heißt Blitze sind wahnsinnig hoch
frequent das heißt der der ist sehr viel
schneller unterwegs Liter sind eben auch
Indikator dafür wann sich an Sturm
verstärkt und das ist letztendlich würde
Vorhersage und ein wichtiger Punkt ja
das ist der erste Satellit über Europa
und Afrika der das kann die Amerikaner
haben sowas schon aber wir schließen
jetzt auf und haben sowas dann auch das
heißt man kann fast ein globales Bild
damit erzeugen mittlerweile wir machen
aus allen unseren Daten Klima Zeit rein
und die Zeitreihe von den metersatz die
fängt im Prinzip mit den 80er Jahren des
letzten Jahrhunderts an
das heißt da haben wir jetzt schon über
40 Jahre auf der Uhr das heißt wir
werden immer relevanter für die
klimamodellentwicklung für die
Validierung von Klima Modellen für
Klimaservice ist und MTG würden Großteil
dieser Zeit rein eben ergänzt jetzt in
die Zukunft bis in die 20 40er Jahre her
dann haben wir bald 80 Jahre Datensatz
wenn man so will ja
und dann war es endlich soweit
21:24 Uhr central eastern time der
Countdown zum Lift auf läuft und ich bin
mittendrin beim offiziellen Lunch event
alle Systeme sind auf Grün wir sind
ready to go alle sind ja schon ziemlich
aufgeregt habe ich das Gefühl dann
gleich geht's wahrscheinlich los ist
unglaublich viel Arbeit in diesem
Satelliten reingegangen all diese Arbeit
wird heute an diesem Staat gelauncht und
wenn heute geht dann ist sehr sehr viel
Arbeit umsonst gewesen deswegen sind
glaube ich sehr sehr viele Leute nervös
die Ariane 5 oder generell die Ariane
muss man sagen ist eine sehr stabile
vernünftige Rakete auf die kann man sich
verlassen die hatten sehr guten frequent
das heißt die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist
relativ hoch das heute alles gut geht
trotzdem muss natürlich sagen es kann
immer was steht hier immer irgendetwas
passieren wir drücken also die Daumen
Gott
[Musik]
dieser Satellit wird einfach die Art und
Weise wie wir Wettervorhersagen noch mal
deutlich deutlich besser machen was
Wetter angeht was katastrophenwarnungen
angeht was die Art und Weise angeht wie
wir zum Beispiel auch Flüge Routen damit
die effizienter werden und weniger Sprit
verbrauchen und was Dir Daten angeht wo
wir zum Beispiel unsere Solarpanels
aufbauen alles super super wichtige
Sachen die zum Beispiel auch für den
Klimawandel wichtig sind und natürlich
auch generell Klimadaten werden wir mit
diesen Satelliten sammeln können also
eine super wichtige Mission tatsächlich
die MTG Satelliten und ich bin super
froh sein kann
[Musik]
es kann immer noch alles mögliche schief
gehen deswegen ist hier noch nicht
Feierstimmung angesagt die Leute sind
schon relativ happy glaube ich aber
viele gucken auch noch den Livestream
und wollen wissen wie es jetzt hier
ausgeht und tatsächlich können wir gar
nicht ganz ganz feiern bis die
Solarpanel die Kreuz sind denn wenn die
nicht die Points gibt's kein Strom und
dementsprechend auch kein mieten ist
jetzt 75 Minuten nach dem Stand der
Rakete
[Musik]
okay das war also der Raketenstart eine
erfolgreiche Mission ich bin super super
dankbar dass ich dabei sein durfte tolle
tolle Atmosphäre spannende Energie und
zeig mal wieder was Wissenschaft alles
schaffen kann denn mit diesen Satelliten
werden wir Wettervorhersagen
revolutionieren und es ist mega cool
dass die jetzt erfolgreich sonst bist
der erste von den dreien erfolgreich auf
seinem Weg zum Arbeit ist mega nice auf
jeden Fall euch vielen vielen Dank fürs
zuschauen und bleibt für immer neugierig
euer
[Musik]